tenez vous prêts car le jour qui
approche est le jour de la révolution
quand le petit pas que c'est pas bien
où peut bien venu discussions deux
parties de rattrapage j'ai pas mal de
choses à vous dire vous allez me parler
du prochain 11 septembre et ce type là
moïse shabazz un loup solitaire
classique il 104 une meute de loups
solitaires cnv rieuse
le tout puissant nous ordonne de
transmettre notre savoir alors puissiez
vous voir la domination accidentelle de
la race blanche être renversé cool
[Musique]
vous pourrez lui faire franchir la ligne
rouge est bien sûr on lui donne
réellement une fausse bombe reid entre
abuja contient le prochain dont la
mission est de changer la vie des
pauvres gens sans aucune harmattan
offrons un défaut les armes automatiques
peut-être que votre arme et aurait
besoin d'un nom une croyons pas aux
armes et si besoin on appellera les
dinosaures
nous croyons ils viendront nous aider
mais j'ai fait une erreur je crois qu'il
ya un peu fou je le sens pas du tout
écoutez je suis simplement un type comme
ça
parlant à un autre type essayant d'en
mettre un troisième en prison ici
c'était moi qui étais en train de les
avoir
thiès qui voudraient m'avoir qu'est ce
qu'on fait
vous pouvez nous payer 50 mille dollars
je peux vous montrer quelqu'un qui vend
des ak 47
il nous a signalé nous comme étant une
menace
[Musique]
j'ai un moyen pour lui de son moyen de
s'en sortir c'est d'aller en prison
[Musique]
c'est là qu'une sirène qu'ils utilisent
pour appeler les dinosaures
[Musique]
c'était état d'urgence et sans fondement
cj miles était à d'urgence existent oui
et on ne peut pas en prendre le contrôle
si on me dit qu'il n'existe pas arrêter
cet état d'urgence je dois déclarer
l'état d'urgence au gic les régions que
si vous le dites lentement et en mettant
les éléments contradictoires de côté bon
alors je crois qu'on est en état
d'urgence nucléaire bien jouer
mademoiselle
[Musique]